Hi, Mystery Recapped here.
Today I am going to explain a Russian science
fiction action film called “Coma.”
Spoilers ahead!
Watch out and take care!
At the beginning of the movie, we are shown
a utopian city with white futuristic buildings
and no people.
But soon, the buildings start to decay and
turn black.
In the following scene, a miniature model
of the same city is in an apartment.
An architect wakes up right next to it and
is confused about his location.
He looks at a picture of himself and a girl
with a distorted face.
Suddenly, the things in the apartment start
to deteriorate.
The architect looks at the blackening ceiling
in surprise and comes out of the room.
Outside, is a stranger who is deteriorating
as well.
The confused man then runs outside the building
and finds himself in a strange world where
buildings are levitating in the sky and the
people are fading away.
He looks around the place in fascination and
comes across a monstrous creature that seems
to be melting and regenerating.
The creature attacks the architect and makes
him fall to the ground.
When he opens his eyes again, two people stand
in front of him.
The group takes the architect and runs away
from the creature who follows them behind.
While in the chase, they jump from building
to building defying the laws of physics.
At one point they even jump on the road right
above them proving that gravity doesn’t
exist in this new world.
Suddenly, they enter a stall and reach the
city of Venice.
The monstrous creature almost gets them but
is shot by Phantom.
However, the attack only slows the creature
as its body reforms right after.
The architect, who is confused out of his
mind, follows the others.
At last, one of them named Pilot jumps in
to stall the creature letting the other three
get away at the expense of his own life.
The architect asks them a lot of questions
about his whereabouts as they take him to
a safe zone.
A girl named Fly reveals that he is in a coma
and has entered a world where all the people
who fall into a coma go.
Since the human brain stores memories like
an electromagnetic field, when one goes into
a coma, the memories become your reality.
Hence the place is a collaborative memory
of everyone in the world in a coma.
This explains the flying buildings and stalls
that lead to different parts of the world.
Still not able to comprehend what is going
on, the architect asks about the creature
that attacked them earlier.
Fly explains that the creature was a braindead
person.
When a person dies in coma they turn into
such creatures called Reapers who have the
ability to turn others into creatures like
them.
Fly, then stops the architect and slowly heals
the wounds in his head.
Finally, the three reach an abandoned old
bus.
They walk in through a door and walk out into
a completely different place through another.
Fly explains that the memories of people are
all jumbled to form this world.
So when a person remembers the bus to be on
a field and another remembers it near a building,
it creates a wormhole-like system that they
just experienced.
Phantom, Fly, and the architect meet a group
of people who are mad because they let Pilot
die.
The leader of the group named Yan tells everyone
it was worth it because now they have the
architect.
He asks Fly to show the guest around and explain
everything to him.
The girl takes him to his room while explaining
why he was brought to the base.
It turns out that their leader Yan got out
of coma once and figured out how the world
of coma works.
None of the people remember who they were
in real life so they use made-up names like
the astronomer, the spirit, and so on.
They live a happy life in the new world except
when they are attacked by the reapers.
Yan believes that there is an island that
doesn’t have any reapers on it so their
group is always looking out for people who
can help them reach the island.
The architect has been brought to the base
for the same reason.
According to Yan, the architect could be of
great importance to them to help build a colony
on the said island.
Fly leaves him alone to get some rest.
At night, the architect dreams of him driving
to a religious place.
He vaguely remembers running out of the place
with a girl and getting into an accident.
When the man wakes up, his room has turned
into the site the accident took place in.
The architect looks at the car and himself
inside it in fascination while the place he
visited before the accident has also materialized
from his dreams.
Just then, Phantom enters the room watching
his dreams come to life.
He sits down and warns the architect to stay
away from Fly.
He also implies that he is the real leader
and Yan is just the brain of the group.
Then, the architect is taken outside for a
test to reveal his power.
Phantom explains that everyone in the group
has one power or the other that derives from
what they were good at in their real life.
For example, a girl named Spirit can tell
when danger is approaching them, Fly can heal
people, Phantom has insane strength, and so
on.
To surface the architect’s strength, he
should be brought face to face with danger
so his flight or fight can activate.
For this purpose, Phantom orders a man to
shoot the architect.
The test begins and the architect is shot
to the ground.
He is also attacked by a robot and is beaten
badly but his powers do not activate.
Seeing that he has failed the test, Yan appoints
him as a manual worker.
A while later, Yan is told that they are running
low on the explosive they use to fight the
reapers.
So, Phantom and the people with special powers
make their way to an explosive factory.
The architect asks to join them on their mission.
Phantom doesn’t want to take him but agrees
when Yan orders him to.
They finally reach the factory and see some
guards.
A confused architect is told that since the
person who dreamt of the factory also imagined
the guards, they will protect the factory
with their life.
The group then attacks the guards and finally
reaches the place where the weapon is hidden.
Two of them climb up the weapon to get it
out but right then, they notice three reapers
coming their way.
Phantom orders the people getting the weapon
to continue while the rest of them run away.
In a time of crisis, the architect’s powers
manifest to life.
He easily creates a bridge using his imagination.
The person on the top of the weapon uses it
to come down below and they run away safely.
Back at the base, everyone praises the architect
for his bravery.
Yan wants to set off to build an island with
the architect as soon as possible.
A surprised Phantom says he wants to discuss
it with Yan first but Yan dismisses him and
makes the astronomer the team leader.
The astronomer has the ability to navigate
through the coma world using maps.
Phantom sarcastically asks Yan to tell the
others the whole truth only to be dismissed.
They plan to start their journey to the safe
place the following day.
At night, the architect tries to build something
like he did in the mission but fails to concentrate.
Fly approaches him and suggests he imagine
the blueprint of the things he wants to build.
As the architect does that, he is able to
create a structure in seconds.
Later, they are in the astronomer’s room
looking at the crashed car.
Fly asks him if the girl in the car is someone
he loves and the astronomer replies that he
doesn’t care.
He has started to like his new life in this
world where he can build wherever he likes.
As they talk, the two end up kissing, unknown
that Phantom has been listening to their conversation
all this time.
The following morning, the group prepares
for the journey.
The astronomer makes a map of the route that
is safe from the reapers.
But before they set off, Phantom brings a
reaper calling whistle with him.
He plans to plant it on the architect so that
he would attract a reaper to himself.
They finally start the journey but have to
stop midway when Spirit senses reapers coming
their way.
Phantom suggests they separate into different
directions to see where they're coming from
and report back.
The architect goes in a direction along with
the whistle that was planted on him by Phantom.
He is soon attacked by a reaper but is saved
by a man named Tank who Yan sent for his help.
They return back to the group when everyone
finds out that Phantom is behind the reapers
following them.
Seeing himself being exposed, Phantom says
something about Yan hiding the truth.
But before he can explain himself, Yan shoots
him, turning him into a reaper as well.
Soon, they are surrounded by many reapers
who kill two of their teammates.
The others manage to run away while still
being followed by them.
They are about to reach the safe zone when
the world around the architect starts disappearing
and he begins to come out of the coma.
His eyes open in the real world and suddenly,
he remembers everything that happened before
the accident.
To his surprise, the girl who got into an
accident with him was Fly.
Before the accident, she drove him to a client
who was a religious leader who had a lot of
devotees.
Fly was scared for the architect’s safety
because the man wasn’t any normal client.
Hence she handed him a taser and waited outside
as he went in for the meeting.
Inside, a man took him to the religious leader
who turned out to be Yan.
All of them then entered a room with several
people on ventilators.
The architect was attacked as the people tried
to sedate him but he managed to escape using
the taser.
Outside, he got into the car with Fly but
they were soon met by an accident.
Back in the present, the architect wakes up
in a hospital bed beside Yan.
He asks Yan who he actually is and finds out
he is a scientist.
Yan had found out about life in coma and wanted
to experiment to make it a liveable world.
Hence, he established himself as a religious
leader to fund his experiment.
Yan saw the architect’s ideas and wanted
to incorporate them into the coma world.
That is why he put both Fly and the architect
into a coma, along with phantom and the others.
The architect retaliates saying that even
if he creates a perfect world, he will be
forcefully making the people stay in it.
Yan retaliates by showing him Phantom’s
real body.
He turns out to be handicapped in real life,
so he enjoyed being in a coma.
Hence, even when Phantom regained all of his
memory in that world, he never revealed it
to anyone.
Yan then asks the architect to go back into
a coma and help him to build the city of his
dreams.
In exchange, he agrees to spare everyone's
lives, including Fly’s.
Knowing that this is the only way to save
everyone, the architect accepts the offer.
Before falling back into a coma, Yan reveals
that there is a way to get out of the coma
from inside the place, but he will only show
it to the architect when his job is done.
In the following scene, the architect again
wakes up in his apartment.
However, this time, he has the memory of how
he reached there.
He creates a bridge and runs to where the
rest of the group is.
But instead of doing what he was told, the
architect reveals that Yan has been lying
to them.
Just then, Yan arrives there and forces him
to create the island just how he wanted him
to.
The architect fulfills his wish and constructs
a magical utopia.
He finally asks Yan to let them go to the
real world now.
However, first, Yan decides to tell them how
miserable their life was outside of the coma.
Spirit was in a mental asylum, Tank was in
jail for killing his neighbors, while astronomer
was an autistic man with poor parents.
He also declares the architect as the worst
of them all as his career was a massive failure.
Hearing this, Fly begins to get her memory
back as well.
Spirit, Tank, and astronomer decide they want
to stay in the utopia but Yan reveals he cannot
let them stay because they know the truth.
Before the group can do anything, the people
from the real world induce cerebral hypoxy
on them, making them brain dead.
Tank dies instantly while the others look
for a way to wake themselves up in the real
world.
They remember that Yan had always warned them
to not look into their materialized dreams,
hence, a way of getting out could be in one
of those dreams.
The group runs back to the base but Spirit
fades away before she can make it.
The others enter the architect’s room and
walk into the building that he was kidnapped
from.
They look for a way to go back into the room
only to see that the place has changed completely
by people’s dreams merging with it.
The astronomer fades away on the way, leaving
the architect and Fly alone.
Right then, the architect notices they are
in a painting that he saw in the room he was
abducted in.
However, Yan appears in front of them before
they can enter the painting.
He is about to kill the two but they are saved
by a reaper at the last second.
The reaper turns out to be Phantom who kills
Yan and lets the two go into the real world
through the painting.
After that, both Fly and the architect wake
up in real life.
They walk out of the place without Yan’s
assistant stopping them.
The scene then changes to some weeks later.
The architect has started working according
to his client’s ideas and has stopped innovating
his own.
He and Fly are a happy couple.
Yan’s religious cult, however, is doing
as good as ever even after his death.
One day, the architect receives a letter from
the group again and keeps it safe with him,
indicating that he might be on his way to
a second trip to the coma world.
Subscribe for more videos like this, turn
on the notification, and leave a like to help
the channel out.
Thanks for watching.